les shadows que sont anéantis par
l'insecte gégène mais heureusement il y
à la lune en ce temps là en effet sur la
terre il y avait la lune mais elle était
de bien moins bonne qualité que celle de
magna s'était pas encore un astre ni
même une planète
ce n'était même pas un satellite de
planète
c'était 1 h un machin qui se promenait à
deux ou trois coups des au dessus des
arbres et des forêts comme un vulgaire
ballon deux fois ce n'est que beaucoup
plus tard qu'elle le parti vert les
espaces extérieurs dans les conditions
que nous verrons par la suite
vous vous rendez bien compte qu'en ce
temps-là par conséquent aller sur la
lune c'était pas plus compliqué que de
monter au grenier à condition d'avoir
des echets la lune et d'emporter son
manger alors qu'angers j'ai ne se
déchaîner
les shadoks couraient se réfugier sur la
lune avec leurs victuailles leur patrie
cuisine leurs ustensiles et leur
affection
c'est ce qu'on appelait en ce temps là
la course à la lune vous devez vous dire
pouvoir à laisser facilement sur la lune
quand on avait des embêtements sur la
terre ça au moins c'était une lutte
intéressante
vous avez raison bien sûr mais pas
tellement cela a sapé la course à la
lune voyez-vous car non seulement gégène
monge et se traînait mais même ceux qui
traînaient pas et bien ils n'étaient pas
tous sauvés obligatoire non parce que
quand la lune était pleine
en quelque sorte et bien elles étaient
trop lourdes est tombée les shadoks au
trot il fallait les jeter et cela
revenait pour thème gégène m'en parle
ce qui reste est à ton modèle dépassé le
temps comme il pouvait et quand gégène
s'était calmé les châteaux prudemment
rentrer dans leur squat et puis
ça recommençait et comme sassou dont
plusieurs fois par jour aller sur la
lune en dire de la lune aller sur la
lune descendre la lune monter descendre
c'était exténuant les châteaux qu'elle
est il pouvoir tenir sur la terre à ce
régime la montée des cendres de la lune
dix vingt cent fois par jour c metex
tellement c'était harassant pour les
malheureux shadoks
d'autant plus qu'il y avait le grave
problème des échelles à l'une les
shadoks n'avait pas d'échelle
suffisamment adéquat
[Musique]
il faut vous dire que les shadoks
n'avait pas encore inventé l'échelle
dite intégral que nous connaissons
maintenant ils étaient donc obligés
d'avoir deux sorte d'échelle d'une part
des échelles pour monter et d'autre part
des échelles pour descendre et c'était
pas les mêmes quand on essayait de
monter par exemple avec une échelle pour
des sens et bien ça marchait pas et même
si ça avait risqué de marché ça aurait
marché beaucoup trop lentement
de même quand on essayait de descendre
avec une échelle pour monter ça marchait
pas non plus ou plus exactement ça
marchait mais beaucoup trop rapidement
évidemment on aurait fait de descendre
en faisant semblant de monter ou vice et
versa mais c'était très risqué parce que
l'échelle au bout d'un certain temps
s'en apercevait alors dans la confusion
les châteaux qui souvent se trompaient
déchets
son regard s'est de plus belle la vie
sur terre décidément c'était pas
[Musique]